[Musica]
Sei brutto Sei grassa non vali niente
sbagli sempre tutto non ce la farai
questi sono solo alcuni degli esempi che
popolano la nostra mente durante la
giornata
variano di intensità contenuto e
frequenza da un momento all'altro della
nostra vita ma rappresentano una
costante della nostra esistenza
una voce che giudica misura commenta in
maniera negativa tutto quello che
facciamo e pensiamo
un costante commentario di noi stessi
che non ci abbandona mai dal momento in
cui Apriamo gli occhi al momento in cui
li chiudiamo sapete di cosa sto parlando
vero
amo parlare in pubblico ma mi provoca
anche molta ansia e nei mesi antecedenti
questo evento la mia mente mi ripeteva
cosa del tipo non ce la farai mai a
nessuno interesserà quello che hai da
dire ti coprirai di ridicolo riceverai
un sacco di critiche e tanto altro
e se faccio attenzione posso sentire
questa voce ancora qui presente anche
oggi in un angolino remoto della mia
mente
questa voce questa critica interna che
lo psicologo americano Stevens chiama il
dittatore interno
ma immaginatevi una vita in cui questa
critica interna Questa voce interna non
rappresenta più un problema e non
condiziona più le scelte che fate o che
non fate
immaginatevi una vita in cui potete
salire su un palco liberi di parlare di
fronte a un pubblico Senza dover temere
il giudizio altrui
immaginatevi una vita in cui potete
andare un colloquio di lavoro un primo
appuntamento libere di essere voi stessi
immaginatevi una vita in cui potete
aprire l'anta di un frigorifero andare a
cena in un ristorante senza
una voce che vi ripete quanto Siete
lontani o lontane dai canoni estetici
imposti dalla società e che vi fa
sentire in colpa per ogni cosa
Ecco questa vita è possibile
questa voce probabilmente non se ne
andrà mai Perché per quanto strano possa
sembrare è qui per proteggerci per
tenerci al sicuro non per farci del male
si forma nei primissimi anni della
nostra vita ed è in parte l'eco della
voce degli adulti significativi che
hanno popolato la nostra infanzia
come abbiamo detto è qui per proteggerci
non per farci del male ma tende a essere
iperprotettiva
E allora andremo a vedere insieme
quattro modi quattro tecniche diverse
per liberarci dalla morsa della critica
interna
primo punto
bisogna Innanzitutto
riconoscerne la presenza bisogna
diventare consapevoli che stiamo
pensando perché di pensieri si tratta
questa voce altro non è che un flusso di
pensieri
intrusivi e spesso automatici a cui
crediamo troppo a cui diamo troppa
importanza
da qui ci lasciamo convincere troppo
semplice rumore mentale ma arriviamo a
percepire la realtà esterna la realtà
che ci circonda attraverso il filtro dei
nostri pensieri e questo è un processo
molto comune è molto ben noti in
psicologia che si chiama fusione
cognitiva
quindi il primo passo è appunto
riconoscere la presenza di questa voce
per evitare di essere persi in questo
incessante dialogo interno per ore e ore
durante la giornata ed ecco un piccolo
consiglio su come fare
chiedetevi spesso durante il giorno che
cosa sta facendo la mia mente ora
Che cosa sta facendo la mia mente ora
per ricordarvi potete scrivere o mettere
delle notifiche sul telefono o
sull'orologio elettronico o scrivere
questa domanda in dei post-it da toccare
sui muri di casa o sullo schermo del
computer che cosa sta facendo la mia
mente ora
questa domanda non ha bisogno di una
risposta precisa ma serve come incentivo
a dirigere la vostra attenzione
sull'attività mentale serve a fare un
passo indietro rispetto al proprio
flusso di pensieri
a rompere quel processo di
identificazione tra noi e i nostri
pensieri quel processo che è quello che
ci fa soffrire più di tutti fare un
passo indietro significa notare i nostri
pensieri per quello che sono ovvero
semplici rumore mentale fare un passo
indietro significa creare spazio
dove posso scegliere come rispondere
alle circostanze esterne nella miniera
più virtuosa possibile
uno spazio di non reattività
e ora al secondo punto date un nome alla
vostra critica interna o alla vostra
mente
la mia si chiama Billy e questa è una
tecnica presa dalla accertatencent
Therapy
quando notate la presenza la critica
interna potete rispondere con frasi del
tipo ti sento Billy ti vedo ti ringrazio
ma non ho bisogno di te in questo
momento dare un nome alla propria mente
non è un modo per burlarsi o per
ridicolizzarla bensì un ulteriore modo
per rompere quel processo di
identificazione con essa un ulteriore
modo per rinforzare quello spazio tra me
e i miei pensieri per notarli per quello
che sono semplice rumore mentale ma
ricordatevi di essere gentili con essa e
di ringraziarla per perché come abbiamo
detto non è qui per farci del male ma
per tenerci al sicuro
una volta che avete notato la presenza
di questa voce l'avete ringraziata
portate la vostra attenzione al momento
presente questo è il terzo punto
ancoratevi al momento presente e andremo
a fare adesso un esercizio tutti insieme
che lo psicoterapeuta rasserris Chiama
gettare L'Ancora quindi vi invito a
sedervi comodi sulla sedia ora
a sistemarvi comodi e a chiudere gli
occhi
se non fosse a vostro agio potete
tenerli aperti
vorrei che portasse ora tutta la vostra
attenzione
sul corpo
lasciatevi assorbire dalle sensazioni
corporee senza giudicarle
notate la presenza del sedere
sulla sedia della schiena sullo
schienale la pressione dei piedi sul
pavimento
muovete le spalle in alto e in basso
e apprezzate nel movimento sentite che
avete un corpo intorno a voi
portate ora la vostra attenzione
all'udito cosa potete sentire
oltre al suono della mia voce
che odori potete percepire
che gusto avete in bocca
e ora potete aprire gli occhi e notare
tre oggetti di fronte a voi
Questo esercizio può essere fatto in
qualsiasi situazione contesto può essere
fatto da seduti in piedi o sdraiati può
essere fatto nella comunità del
soggiorno di casa o a un meeting di
lavoro può essere fatto mentre si
viaggia sui mezzi mentre si fa la spesa
mentre si è rilassati o agitati non
importa il contesto Dove siete Cosa fate
ogni qualvolta notate la presenza della
critica interna ringraziatela e portate
l'attenzione al qui ed ora
perché quando siete nel puro qui ed ora
nel mero presente come dice il grande
cartole non ci può essere sofferenza
perché la sofferenza ha bisogno della
dimensione temporale per sopravvivere
quando la critica interna vi trascina
nel passato e vi sbatte nel futuro voi
gettate L'Ancora estate nel presente e
anche se doveste distrarvi un milione di
volte al giorno voi per un milione di
volte
ringraziatela e riportate l'attenzione
al momento presente
e ora al quarto punto e forse anche
quello più importante di tutti non
entrate in dialogo con la vostra mente
perché ne uscirete sempre con le ossa
rotte non entrate in dibattito in
dialogo con quei pensieri che sono lì da
anni magari che risalgono pure
all'infanzia non entrate in dibattito
con quei pensieri che sembrano come
incastrati appiccicati dentro la testa
perché potrete vincere qualche round ma
perderete sempre il match
Magari avete provato per anni
a convincervi che questa voce non aveva
ragione
Magari avete provato per anni a
ripetervi affermazioni positive davanti
a uno specchio o a cercare di
rimpiazzare questi pensieri
con altri più piacevoli
Magari avete provato per anni a
distrarvi a non pensarci Ma neppure
quello ha funzionato
Come dice il grande Emoji
cercare di fermare la mente è proprio
come cercare di fermare il vento vestiti
da aquiloni
E allora se non posso fermare la mente
se non posso semplicemente non pensarci
o rimpiazzare questi pensieri con altri
più piacevoli
cosa posso fare
la lascio parlare lascio che questi
pensieri entrino ed escano come e quando
vogliono
e li osservo osservo il processo senza
giudicare
quando la mente vi dice cose orribili
che fate schifo che non valete niente
che nessuno vi ama che non appartenete
che sbagliate sempre tutto voi non
entrate in dialogo con essa
ma riconoscete la presenza innanzitutto
di questi pensieri notate che state
pensando e Ringraziate la vostra mente
portate l'attenzione al momento presente
e continuate a fare quello che state
facendo ma non entrate in dialogo con
essa ovviamente è molto più semplice a
dirsi che a farsi ma serve molta pratica
pratica giornaliera perché è difficile
ma fattibile
e ora Volevo lasciarvi con una storia
vecchia di 2600 anni ci troviamo in
India
Siddharta Gautama è seduto in
meditazione
sotto a un albero
non è ancora al Buddha mancano poche ore
al suo risveglio e mentre seduto
concentrato in meditazione
viene visitato da Mara Mara nel Buddismo
è un demone un'entità maligna tentatrice
che tenta Siddharta proprio come fece
Satana col Cristo nel deserto
Mara tinta Siddharta dapprima con
fantasie sessuali e poi
cercando di instillare in lui il dubbio
che non aveva il diritto di essere lì a
fare quello che stava facendo
che non aveva il diritto di imbarcarsi
in un'impresa tanto grossa quella di
trovare una via d'uscita dalla
sofferenza umana
a quel punto Siddharta cosa fa
non si metta a litigare con Mara
non cerca di convincersi del contrario
né si ripeta affermazioni positive Ma
guarda Mara dritto negli occhi
e gli dice ti vedo Mara
ti riconosco Per quello che sei
e tutto il potere che Mara aveva
sussidata scomparve Grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]